I spent the last couple weeks touring  around the Midwest and I loved being a  good West but it's summertime and I'm  not used to the humidity it is humidity  you can tell it's humid somewhere you  can tell the team in st. Louis up dudes  walking down the street limit  sneaky Sexy's in there it was something  that things like a fruit roll-up on both  sides we abandon the wall  I'm not pretty  some people a little disgusting you see  dude what you see the channel  you tip your hat you say good day sir  listen I would say this sweet Papa loose  roll  this move is is Jim here's how fast I'm  up there and his third disturbed move my  brother goes because  dentistry mystery plane speeds look at  you  [Music]  [ __ ] you that's aggressive  we can't a eyeball forward on your  jingling  [Music]  you